hemos hecho muchos vídeos en khan
academy sobre evolución y selección
natural y creo que ya tenemos una mejor
comprensión sobre cómo evoluciona la
vida para crear la variedad la
diversidad y la complejidad que vemos a
nuestro alrededor pero aún tenemos una
pregunta fundamental sin resolver tal
vez esta sea la pregunta más importante
para nosotros y es el origen de la vida
cómo fue que emergió la vida por primera
vez al menos en el planeta tierra y eso
nos lleva a otras preguntas existirá
vida fuera de este planeta como sería
pero empecemos con lo que sabemos hasta
ahora dibujaré una línea del tiempo
regresemos hasta hace mil millones de
años dos mil millones de años tres mil
millones de años cuatro mil millones de
años ok entonces este es el presente y
aquí son mil millones de años atrás que
es una cantidad de tiempo insondable
pero sabemos que la tierra junto con el
resto del sistema solar
hace aproximadamente 4.6 mil millones de
años ahí fue cuando se formó la tierra y
se cree que 100 millones de años antes
de los 4.5 mil millones de años atrás la
tierra todavía no tenía las condiciones
adecuadas para la vida ni siquiera para
la forma de vida más simple y eso era
porque en ese momento el sistema solar
era un lugar muy alocado había
colisiones en todas partes y todo el
tiempo de hecho la luna se formó gracias
a la colisión de dos objetos del tamaño
de planetas aún no se le conoce como
proto tierra y ese objeto chocó con otro
proto planeta y comenzaron a dar vueltas
y con el tiempo así fue como se formó la
luna pero podemos imaginar que en este
momento no había un medio ambiente
adecuado para la formación de la vida
incluso cuando se formó la luna existía
un gran bombardeo en el sistema solar en
ese momento el sistema solar era un
desastre
que pasar mucho tiempo para lograr la
estabilidad que ahora conocemos se cree
que hasta hace tres punto nueve mil
millones de años la tierra empezó a
tener las condiciones adecuadas para la
aparición de la vida porque antes de eso
había períodos en los que el bombardeo
se detenía y tal vez algún tipo de vida
primitiva llegó a existir pero después
desaparecía con un bombardeo muy fuerte
o quién sabe tal vez sobrevivieron de
alguna manera pero al menos esa es la
creencia oficial y bueno se han
encontrado fósiles del inicio de la vida
de hace 3.5 mil millones de años y esas
evidencias son estromatolitos
microorganismos que originalmente
formaron algunas de las estructuras que
actualmente siguen existiendo y aunque
se piensa que los microorganismos no son
tan complejos si pensamos detenidamente
en lo que ocurre adentro de un
microorganismo podríamos ver que son
increíblemente complejos
realmente si los comparamos con los
seres inertes entonces la creencia
actual es que en algún punto de esta
región comenzó la vida en el planeta
tierra pero aún cuando lo supiéramos con
esa actitud por ejemplo que dijéramos o
fue exactamente hace 3.7 mil millones de
años cuando el rn logró obtener la
configuración adecuada por primera vez y
pudo comenzar a replicarse a sí mismo de
alguna forma no aun cuando la fecha
exacta sigue sin conocerse
tal vez una pregunta más interesante es
él como al menos para mí el como es más
interesante que el cuándo y para el cómo
podemos empezar con las moléculas más
simples que esperaríamos encontrar al
inicio de la tierra aquí tenemos algunos
ejemplos
esta es la molécula de h2o comúnmente
conocida como agua después tenemos el
co2 más conocido como dióxido de carbono
aquí tenemos nitrógeno molecular después
amoniaco
y muchos de los elementos y moléculas
que existen actualmente en el planeta
posiblemente ya existían desde el inicio
de la tierra pero cómo fue que
intervinieron para formar moléculas
orgánicas ligeramente más complejas
bueno cuando las personas hablan de
moléculas orgánicas hablan de moléculas
como éstas los aminoácidos que de alguna
forma podríamos decir que son los
bloques de construcción de las proteínas
aminoácidos y de este lado tenemos a los
nucleótidos que son los bloques de
construcción del arn o el adn entre
otros y bueno estas no son las únicas
moléculas orgánicas simples también
están los azúcares y otro tipo de cosas
pero la pregunta aquí es será esto
realista realmente sabemos cómo fue que
pasamos de estas moléculas simples a
otras más complejas ahora conocidas como
moléculas orgánicas y la respuesta más
simple de acuerdo a toda la evidencia
que se conoce hasta ahora es que esto si
es posible se puede pasar de estas
moléculas a estas a biótica mente es
decir sin la presencia de vida
seguramente han escuchado mucho la
palabra antibiótico y un antibiótico
mata la vida mata las bacterias así que
a bióticos significa sin vida y hasta
ahora se ha encontrado evidencia de que
existen aminoácidos y moléculas
orgánicas relacionados a ellos en
cometas meteoritos e incluso en otros
planetas y que se formaron
espontáneamente en el espacio sin la
presencia de vida y también hemos sido
capaces de formar aminoácidos y otras
moléculas como estas en el laboratorio a
partir de este tipo de moléculas simples
miren el experimento más famoso es el
experimento de miller yuri que se
realizó en los años 50 con un poco de
energía provocaron una chispa podemos
imaginar eso en la tierra temprana
porque pudo ocurrir a partir de los
relámpagos y también inyectaron una
mezcla de gases que ellos creían que era
muy parecida a la mezcla que existía en
la atmósfera de ese entonces que no
contenía mucho oxígeno porque se
necesitaba vida para que se empezara a
producir un poco de ese oxígeno y bueno
aunque actualmente se piensa que la
mezcla que crearon no era totalmente
correcta lograron algo muy importante
demostraron que con esa mezcla de gases
que ellos pensaban que estaban en la
atmósfera y un poco de energía en el
sistema se pudieron formar algunas de
estas moléculas orgánicas así que
deberíamos sentirnos muy bien de que al
menos este primer paso es realista ahora
la siguiente pregunta es que bueno estas
moléculas orgánicas por sí solas no son
vida de hecho éstas no son las moléculas
más complejas que son esenciales para la
vida pero las proteínas son lo que hacen
que todo se vuelva más interesante y una
proteína puede tener miles de
ácidos de aminoácidos y se cree que
otras cosas como el adn y el rn también
son esenciales para la vida o al menos
para la vida como la conocemos y por
ejemplo para formar una molécula de adn
se necesitan de millones de nucleótidos
entonces esta es solamente una pequeña
parte pero es mucho más compleja de lo
que podemos ver aquí y también existe
evidencia de que podemos formar
proteínas a partir de aminoácidos o adn
a partir de nucleótidos sin presencia de
vida se ha demostrado que esto puede
ocurrir espontáneamente si tenemos las
condiciones y la energía disponible
incluso muchas personas se han dado
cuenta de que si tenemos las superficies
adecuadas estas moléculas pueden
organizarse correctamente para formar
otras más complejas
tal vez estén pensando ok las proteínas
están muy bien el adn y el rn están muy
bien pero como es que esas moléculas se
convierten en vida en qué punto podemos
decir que se forma la vida bueno eso nos
lleva a un terreno desconocido porque la
verdad es que no lo sabemos pero ya
existen dos hipótesis para eso una se
conoce como la hipótesis del mundo de la
rn vamos a escribir la hipótesis del
mundo
del a r n
esta es la idea de que la primera
aparición de la vida fue a partir de la
auto replicación de las moléculas de rn
y la razón por la que las personas se
concentran un poco más en el arn que en
el adn es porque incluso actualmente el
arn en las células no solamente almacena
información sino que también puede jugar
un papel como catalizador
por ejemplo cuando pensamos en cosas
como el aire n ribosomal así que tal vez
la primera aparición de la vida fue con
el aire en la información se replicó a
sí misma y catalizó la replicación por
sí misma y después tal vez de alguna
forma se organizó formando estructuras y
membranas con lo que se crearon
ambientes separados del mundo exterior
pero bueno la respuesta más simple al
origen de la vida es que no lo sabemos
otra hipótesis muy popular es la
hipótesis del primer metabolismo
primero metabolismo
esta es la idea de que de los muchos
caminos básicos que se estudian en un
libro de bioquímica este fue uno de los
primeros que ocurrió en este escenario
en donde tenemos estas moléculas
orgánicas bajo las condiciones adecuadas
entonces el primer metabolismo es uno de
los mecanismos que ahora estudiamos en
bioquímica y tal vez se ocurrió dentro
de una célula o quién sabe pero
simplemente creo más y más complejidad
hasta que en algún punto todo empezó a
ocurrir de forma autor organizada en
estructuras como las membranas o tal vez
en realidad fue una combinación de estas
dos hipótesis pero bueno nuevamente la
respuesta más simple es que no lo
sabemos aunque actualmente existen
indicios muy interesantes por ejemplo si
analizamos las proteínas podemos ver que
sus estructuras son muy comunes para
toda la vida como la conocemos y tal vez
eso nos pueda dar más indicios sobre
cómo fue la primera aparición de vida